YUFENG GUO: Getting explanations
for your predictions
is becoming
increasingly important.
How can we use Cloud AI
Platform's Prediction service
to generate explanations?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to "AI Adventures" where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we're going to explore AI
Explanations, which is now
built into Cloud AI
Platform's Prediction service,
allowing you to have feature
attributions for each
and every one of
your predictions.
AI Explanations integrates
feature attributions
into AI Platform
Prediction and it
helps you understand
your model's outputs
for classification
and regression tasks.
This means AI
Explanations can tell you
how much each
feature in the data
contributed to the
predicted results.
This is super useful
because you can then
verify the model is behaving
as you would expect, recognize
bias as it's happening, and get
ideas for how you can improve
your training data and model.
Feature attributions are
available for tabular data as
well as image data,
and are specific
to individual predictions.
Currently, there is the
limitation in AI Explanations
that it only supports models
trained on TensorFlow 1.x.
And if you're using Keras
to specify your model,
you will need to convert
it into an estimator using
the model to estimator utility.
Now, let's talk a little
bit about the particulars
of feature attribution
and how it works.
AI Explanations
offers two methods--
sampled Shapley and
integrated gradients.
Both methods are based on the
concept of Shapley values,
which is a cooperative
game theory algorithm that
assigns credit to
each player in a game
for a particular outcome.
Here, each feature is treated
as a player in that game.
And proportional
credit is assigned
to each of those features for
the outcome of a prediction.
Integrated gradients
are best suited
for differential models
like neural networks.
It's especially useful for
models with large feature
spaces.
It computes the gradients
of the output with respect
to the input,
multiplied element-wise
with the input itself.
For those who remember
their calculus class,
this is, essentially, a Taylor
approximation of the prediction
function at the input.
Bet you didn't expect to
see a Taylor approximation
reference today.
Now, let's talk briefly about
the other feature attribution
method--
sampled Shapley.
It assigns credit for the
outcome of each feature
and also considers different
permutations of those features,
and is most suitable for
non-differential models
like ensembles of trees.
There are a number of
articles and research papers
which dive way deeper into these
explainability methods which
I've linked to below.
They're all very well-written
and super interesting to read.
So if you like these topics, I
would encourage you to dive in
and check them out.
If you are ready to
try out AI Explanations
for your deployed model,
head on over to the guides
in the documentation.
There's one for tabular data
and another one for image data.
And, best of all, they're
presented as Colab notebooks,
so it's super easy
to try it out.
One final note
before we wrap up.
Last episode, we talked
about the What-If Tool,
an open-source tool
for understanding
your model's predictions.
AI Explanations can be used in
concert with the What-If Tool
to get an even more
in-depth understanding
of your predictions.
The process for doing that is
also detailed in those Colab
notebooks I mentioned
earlier, and I'll
be sure to link to it in
the description below.
Thanks for watching this episode
of Cloud "AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed it,
click that Like button,
and be sure to subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, check out AI
Explanations on Google Cloud AI
Platform to get your
predictions explained.
[MUSIC PLAYING]